let's start with something a little
different today over the last few weeks
I started getting emails like this one
that I'm putting up on the screen saying
David now that Joe Rogan has been proven
right about the vaccines now that
Russell Brand and Kim Iverson have been
proven right about the vaccines and you
were wrong
are you going to apologize are you going
to issue a retraction or a traction for
Howard Stern fans to what you said now
initially I had no idea what these
people were talking about but indeed
there are a whole bunch of Clips out
there from people like Jimmy Dore a
video called Joe Rogan proven right
about vaccines and myocarditis Russell
Brand did a video myocarditis and Matt
Hancock the great covid swindle a woman
named Kim Iverson who I guess only does
vaccine content now when I looked at her
channel it's like just months of only
vaccine stuff she did a video why
Florida halts covet mRNA for men 18 to
39 and then she also did a video in
August called massive study proves men
under 40 have a higher risk of
myocarditis
post-vaccination so they are claiming
that they have been Vindicated and some
of my viewers are writing to me and
saying David all of these people have
been Vindicated and you were wrong so
let's see if we can talk this through
the first question is what they believe
is Vindication is they say they are
right to be skeptical and reluctant
about the covet vaccine because of
myocarditis and that that has now been
Vindicated now the first part of this
that's sort of strange
is that all of these videos came out in
early to mid-november and one in August
that I talked about and yet the study
that they are all talking about was
published in April of this year that's
almost eight months ago huh
strange right I mean the study is
published eight months ago and they all
talk about it within a few days of each
other in November
that should at least raise a question
and it said all should also make us
wonder if all of these videos were
produced in November but they're talking
about an April study is there any other
study data that came out between April
and November that they excluded from
their videos well we're going to figure
that out but let's start with the study
from April the big takeaway from the
April study is that men under the age of
40
have a higher risk of myocarditis
post-vaccination compared to those who
have not been vaccinated now the study
actually says in it quote further
long-term studies will be needed to
estimate the incidence of pericarditis
and myocarditis in patients diagnosed
with covid this is critical
it's not new information that there is a
small risk of pericarditis and
myocarditis particularly to younger men
from the MRNA covet vaccines we knew
that it was a known risk very rare but a
known risk so that part isn't actually
news but what these folks want to imply
and some of them are straight up saying
is that the risk of pericarditis and
myocarditis from covid is lower than
that from the vaccine in other words the
vaccine is more dangerous than covid the
study they are citing specifically
doesn't say that it says you've got to
study that in order to figure out what
is the incidence of pericarditis and
myocarditis in people who get coveted
that's number one so what they are
implying the study doesn't actually say
secondly no one claimed the vaccine had
no risks nobody claimed there were we
all talked about the side effects this
specific risk was known and it was
Quantified and it's really rare So
pretending that learning that is
newsworthy also is dishonest now the
more you delve into the data and again
they're saying here's a study from April
there are newer studies which we will
get to but this they want to focus on
this study from April the more you delve
into the data the less stunning and
shocking and surprising that the data is
an article from the American College of
Cardiology called which covet vaccine
you get can impact myocarditis risk
comments on the study and clarifies that
quote incidence of myocarditis is two to
three-fold higher after the second dose
of the moderna vaccine when compared to
the Pfizer vaccine however overall cases
of heart inflammation with either
vaccine are very rare this is super
important because again the studies from
April we already knew this we already
knew there's a slightly higher risk of
myocarditis from the vaccine it's
slightly higher from the moderna than
the Pfizer vaccine but the super
important part is you know how sometimes
you hear these claims Health claims and
I'm making this one up this is an
imaginary Health claim but it'll go
something like this
eating persimmon
doubles your risk of spontaneous
blindness this is a joke okay we're
making this up eating persimmon doubles
your risk of spontaneous blindness and
then you find out the risk of
spontaneous blindness in the general
population is 0.01 percent
and the people who ate persimmon went
randomly blind twice as frequently
0.02 percent of the time right
is that significant is that something
that you would alter your behavior
around particularly if eating persimmon
had other health benefits
that's an important analogy to what is
being talked about here now many doctors
including guy whitberg who's an MD and
an mph he's a cardiologist at the rabine
medical center in Israel
he said this information suggests that
if you have any kind of underlying
cardiovascular disease get the Pfizer
vaccine instead of the moderna that's a
doctor's takeaway from this study that's
the takeaway now to go further
many other studies don't even find that
myocarditis is more prevalent in those
that take a vaccine versus who don't
take a vaccine so they're talking in
November about an April study there are
newer studies that don't replicate this
result in August of 2022 but uh this
August right I mean three months ago the
American Heart Association published a
study reporting that quote the risk of
myocarditis is greater after a covet
infection than after covet vaccination
and remains modest after sequential
doses of the booster however the risk of
myocarditis after vaccination is higher
in younger men particularly after a
second dose of the MRNA vaccine
information we knew mostly and making it
clear it seems that covid carries the
higher risk that happens to come from a
study
which was published in August of this
year now that is a four-month newer
study than the one Jimmy Dore and
Russell Brand and Kim Iverson are
looking at
meaning they chose or didn't care or
didn't look to see are there newer
studies that conflict with the one from
April that we're all titillated by but
we have something kind of even more
interesting and it's even newer
information an October study so this is
last month from Penn State College
called quote myocarditis induced by
covet infection is substantially greater
than the risk posed by vaccines
this study found myocarditis induced by
covet infections is worse than that
myocarditis induced by the vaccines okay
that's from last month and the other
part of this is
even if you imagine that the risk of
myocarditis is higher from the vaccine
than it is from covid or rather that
they are the same if you say okay well
myocarditis is is more likely when you
get a vaccine and it's more likely when
you get coveted imagine that we Grant
both of those equally
the myocarditis associated with the
vaccine is milder than the myocarditis
associated with covid that's an
important consideration
a Dr Nicola Klein who's a vaccine expert
at Kaiser Permanente says quote
vaccine-associated myocarditis is
usually milder than the viral type
that's if the risk were equal and many
studies say that's not the case many
studies find this and we're putting
another article up on the screen
here is how some of the commentators I
just mentioned reported on this Jimmy
Dore when talking about this said before
we give forgiveness for the people who
were Nazis around covid policy who were
pro-lockdown pro-mandates and they were
100 wrong on all that stuff it's okay to
be wrong about that stuff what's not
okay is to then demonize people who
disagree with you on facts
well what are the facts choosing an
eight-month-old study when there are
newer studies multiple newer studies
that disagree I don't know
so that's what's going on there's no
retraction needed there's no apology
needed most of this study comes out with
information that's not new
the parts that are more
notable have already been contradicted
by multiple newer studies I have no
horse in this race I want the truth and
I want the healthiest Public Health
situation for everybody
that's it so uh that is the information
as I know it if you have additional
information I should be considering or
evaluating by all means send it to me if
you like these types of segments make
sure to subscribe on YouTube on the page
for this video like if you're watching
this video right now hit subscribe we
see the analytics of which Clips
generate subscribers and if this is of
interest to the audience we will
absolutely do more of these we're going
to take a quick break and be right back
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
lest we forget remember that the David
packman show is a community funded
program we depend on the support of our
viewers our listeners podcast
subscribers people who watch a clip on
YouTube or listen to us on the radio or
even seeing the tick tock videos where
things are blowing up very quickly I'll
say more about that probably on the
bonus show soon because it is
interesting what's happening on Tick
Tock but my invitation to you
is to get the extra content get the
bonus show get the commercial free audio
and video streams of the show simply by
signing up at joinpakman.com that's all
you have to do you go to joinpakman.com
you can use the coupon code 24 starts
now because it does if you prefer you
can use the coupon code please no more
Trump and you have to say it like that
at least in your head when you type it
in please no more Trump uh both coupon
codes save you big time off of the cost
of a membership at joinpakman.com we
will of course get to the doj special
counsel that has been announced it is
starting all up again and I will tell
you what this likely means but before we
get to that I want to go to a completely
bizarre surreal clip of loser Republican
gubernatorial candidate from Arizona
Kerry Lake she was at Mar-A-Lago for
some kind of event and she made a
declaration she says that she is going
to fight what happened in Arizona
now you know and I know that what
happened in Arizona is she lost
what happened in Arizona is the other
candidate Katie Hobbs got more votes
and when things work as planned the
candidate who gets more votes
becomes the governor
very difficult concept apparently for
Kerry Lake listen to this and she got
the hero's welcome and she's like we're
gonna fight this started the incredible
[Music]
they had to do everything they could to
stop us ballot harvesting actually yeah
they had to vote they had to shut down
the machine
day but we know their tricks and they
think they can slow and pour cold water
on a movement now I want you all to
understand she says what they did was
ballot harvesting and to uh what was the
word she said turn off or slow down they
had to do everything they could to stop
us balance harvesting they had to shut
down the machines on Election Day ah
right so the issue she's citing that has
some substance is that there was an
issue at a few Maricopa County locations
because of a couple of malfunctioning
machines the machines were fixed and the
Republican Party originally filed the
lawsuit dropped their lawsuit because it
was all taken care of did not
substantively affect the election ballot
harvesting is just something they repeat
I don't even think they know what it
means but we know their tricks and they
think they can slow and pour cold water
on a movement it is not possible people
you cannot stop the American Spirit
you cannot stop the founding fathers one
person is clapping and the blood that we
have that we have inside of us
and so I will fight what happened on
Tuesday of what was it two weeks ago now
where are we two weeks in we we vote for
a month in Arizona we count both votes
for two weeks and look it's a joke our
elections are a circus run by clowns
I love that we are going to fight what
happened what does that even mean you
just lost how do you fight the fact that
you lost by lying and claiming that you
won so don't for a second
I I I don't want I know most people in
my audience would never fall for
something like this
don't even allow to enter your brain
that anything other than Katie Hobbs
becoming the governor is going to happen
in Arizona now maybe Carrie lake is
going to fight this by running for
governor again in the future if she's
not Trump's VP which she wants to be and
we'll get to that a little bit later but
all that happened is that she lost and
she wants to fight that
I don't think she's going to be
successful
the Department of Justice has announced
a special counsel to investigate and
potentially bring criminal charges
against failed former president Donald
Trump indictment seems imminent
according even to many right-wing legal
Scholars even Trump's lawyers reportedly
are preparing for an indictment Trump is
losing his mind over this and we'll get
to that in a moment what is it that is
going to take place here well CNN
reporting doj announces special counsel
for trump-related Mar-A-Lago and January
6 criminal investigations multiple
criminal investigations at this time
Merritt Garland the Attorney General
appointed a special counsel to oversee
these investigations both investigations
implicate the conduct of trump who is
now a presidential candidate Garland
said based on recent developments
including Trump's announcement that he's
a candidate for president and the
sitting president stated intention to be
a candidate as well I have concluded it
is in the public interest to appoint a
special counsel that special counsel is
going to be a guy named Jack Smith
Jack Smith is the former Chief
prosecutor for the special Court in The
Hague where he investigated war crimes
in Kosovo Smith quote has built the
reputation as an impartial and
determined prosecutor that is absolutely
correct and these right-wingers and
trumpists have wasted no time in going
right into the character assassination
that we should expect about Jack Smith I
don't even want to devote time to that
right now if it becomes a bigger part of
the story and maybe it will because all
these people have his character
assassination maybe we will talk a
little bit more about Jack Smith Jack
Smith's appointment and his selection is
completely uncontroversial it is he's
just a normal
uncontroversial prosecutor okay so what
is it that is going to happen here
continued CNN article according to
multiple sources both the Mar-A-Lago
investigation and the January 6th
investigation around Trump are aiming to
gather more information and bring
Witnesses into a Federal grand jury in
the coming weeks
this is a really big deal
I know that many of you like me have
become desensitized to this because
everything about this failed former
presidency has been so unusual and so
out of what is typical but this is
really not normal we grand juries for
multiple potential crimes committed by a
former president who lost after one term
tried to stay in office despite losing
and is now running again potentially
because he thinks it will help him avoid
these investigations which Merit Garland
says it will not
some of the witnesses being pursued in
this round had not spoken to the
investigators in cases before many in
Trump's orbit believed in hoped the
investigation was slowed or halted
because they hadn't heard from the
justice department for weeks well okay
that isn't going to go on so there's two
views of this decision now if we zoom
out officially the decision is clear
Merit Garland was hired by Joe Biden Joe
Biden has stated his intention to run
for re-election the target of this
investigation is Donald Trump Donald
Trump has now said he's running for for
not re-election but for another election
and as a result Garland's boss could
potentially face off against the guy
he's investigating in order to remove
himself from possible allegations of
political bias here Merit Garland has
done the obvious thing which is to
appoint a special counsel to say you
come in and figure this all out I we
won't get involved in the charging
decisions now there's two views on this
one View
and I heard it from a couple of you is
that Merit Garland is a coward Merritt
Garland is afraid to actually do the
thing that many prosecutors seem to be
afraid to do which is to charge Donald
Trump we saw this in New York we saw the
South elsewhere they are afraid to be
the first to say all right you know what
the evidence is there
the standards have been met
I'm going to be the first to charge a
former president that's one perspective
and there is no doubt that there are
many prosecutors extraordinarily
hesitant and you could argue scared to
charge a former president I concede that
the second view is that Garland is smart
to distance himself from this ultimate
decision that it's predictable that
because Trump announced this campaign
you really just can't have I mean think
of the counter counter uh point to this
which would be Trump says I am now a
candidate
he's campaigning
and Joe Biden's attorney general is
investigating Trump
Fox News wouldn't let that fly as much
as they seem to be distancing from Trump
right-wing media Republicans wouldn't
let that fly
so whether or not you think Garland is a
coward and he may be I mean it's I'm not
weighing in on that it's neither here
nor there
I don't think Garland had any choice he
can't actively be
in an Administration that could be
running against Trump and investigating
trump it just doesn't look good now when
you zoom out a little further there are
a number of legal experts who have
looked at this and said you this is
what's going on this is speculation but
there's a lot of consensus behind it
Garland probably realizes at this point
the evidence against Trump is so strong
he's going to end up getting charged one
way or another either for the stolen
documents or for something related to
January 6th and Garland
needs to be able to as quickly as
possible separate himself from the line
prosecutors and the final steps of that
investigation and I believe that it is
accurate that he should be doing that
but many are also seeing this and saying
this also suggests the indictment is
imminent obviously if that indictment
comes we will have it for you let's now
look at Donald Trump's reaction to this
a visibly scared Donald Trump
flipped out during a Gala the other day
over a special Council being selected by
Merrick Garland to investigate his
crimes you have to see Trump at this
thing he was in rare form and I don't
mean because he was wearing a tuxedo and
looking more orange than ever although
that was notable and interesting to see
Trump saying isn't this all kind of like
double jeopardy impeachment and by the
way I apologize for the terrible audio
that's an issue in the room apparently
the audio text must have been antifa 46
and they tried it in the Senate they
went through the whole process and we
won we went through the whole process so
wouldn't this sort of be a
and then you take a look at the other we
went through two of them and this is
just sort of like double jeopardy in the
old days they used to call it double
jeopardy but essentially uh we've done
so well and we did well in a very
hostile cup yeah
um it's not Double Jeopardy Double
Jeopardy is the prosecution of a person
more than once for the same offense
Trump thinks Double Jeopardy is they
keep finding out of new crimes you might
have committed and those crimes are
investigated he's clearly scared he's
clearly making no sense and there was a
hilarious statement actually that Trump
gave to Fox digital where he said quote
I have been proven innocent for six
years on everything from fake
impeachment to Mueller who found no
collusion and now I have to do it more I
am not going to partake in it I announce
and then they appoint a special
prosecutor the appointment of the
special prosecutor right after he
announces is the proper thing to do not
doing it would be a problem and of
course Trump is wrong that he has been
proven innocent he doesn't seem to
understand how anything Works uh he also
was impeached for things that they
weren't fake they mostly happened in
public and they're recorded
um Mueller did not find no collusion
Mueller decided not to prosecute and
Trump's saying he won't partake won't
really do anything it doesn't make it go
away back to the gala
Trump commenting on the special counsel
he said I thought that was case closed
this horrendous abuse of power is the
latest in a long series of witches
he started a long time ago I thought the
investigation with the document hoax was
dying or dead or over and the
investigation into January 6 and my very
peaceful and patriotic speech remember
peaceful and patriotically
was dead especially after the
record-setting 40-point loss of Liz
Cheney in the equation he seems to think
that because Cheney lost the
investigation the criminal investigation
is over I mean just a total lack of
understanding of anything
I thought that put the final nail in the
coffin
only to find out that the corrupt and
highly political justice department just
appointed a super radical left special
counsel better referred to as a special
prosecutor to start the process all over
again we thought it was this guy's
scared you can genuinely tell there is
absolutely fear there and then he went
into his bizarre hyperbole like saying
there's no one more innocent than Trump
I've proven to be one of the most honest
and innocent people ever in our country
has proven to be one of the most honest
and innocent people ever in our country
Trump speaking at the same Gala actually
brought up uh Carey Lake and said what
happened with her is incredible and that
that isn't even over check this out
Carrie Lake who just went through an
incredible election
there were a lot of broken voting
machines you heard that lots of them
happened to be in largely Republican
areas and uh what happened there is a
disgrace but I want to just tell you you
did some job carry and I know it's not
over yet it is over it is over and there
were a few tabulators that for a period
of time were not working in some parts
of Maricopa County uh everything was
fixed the GOP which had filed a lawsuit
retracted the lawsuit Kerry Lake lost it
is over uh Donald Trump also started
calling for the feds to invade the homes
of the clintons and the bushes which was
a very strange moment they have to
invade this is Mar-A-Lago they have to
invade Hillary and Bill Clinton's
beautiful home in Westchester they have
to invade the Bush's home they have to
invade a lot of homes
but they didn't do that and they took
documents they took a lot of things and
that's what we have the presidential
records act for
calling for you know it's funny on the
one hand he says law enforcement and the
FBI have been politicized and weaponized
and now he's saying they should do it to
the bushes and clintons even though they
aren't actually invest under
investigation for any crimes and then
lastly this is just kind of funny
even C-SPAN pulling away from coverage
of this
Chicago recently
that 82 people shot 82 over weekend but
they said it was a long weekend Oh okay
that's better
[Music]
[Applause]
it was a long weekend in Afghanistan
when I was in charge we didn't have one
killing think of it in 18 months now one
of our soldiers were killed and then you
look at Chicago and you look at other
things
former president Trump has moved on to
other topics we'll take this opportunity
to move on with our program schedule
that's the best other topics Trump's
entire speeches are moving on are moving
on to other topics that's all he does
move on to other topics so absolutely
surreal he looks terrified he looks
genuinely terrified we will have all of
these clips on our Instagram and
remember we are preparing for 2024 as
well pushing for 2 million YouTube
subscribers last month more than three
million different YouTube viewers
watched Clips but didn't subscribe help
us get to 2 million simply by hitting
the Subscribe button right now
if you were not yet subscribed to the
channel we could do it overnight just
with our existing viewers if they hit
that subscribe button help us out we're
going to take a quick break and be back
with so much more we're going to talk
about the runoff we're going to talk
about VP so many different things
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show as the
December 6 runoff for the Georgia Senate
election gets closer and closer one
candidate Rafael Warnock is making more
and more sense the other candidate
Herschel Walker is increasingly unable
to speak we're going to look at clips of
both options that Georgia voters have on
December 6 remember that if you vote in
Georgia the Senate races are not over we
know Democrats will control the Senate
but will it be 50 50 or 5149 that's
going to come down to a runoff election
in Georgia the reason there is a runoff
is that Georgia has something called the
50 rule
the 50 rule states that if not If no
candidate in a regular election gets to
50 of the vote the top two vote Getters
will have a runoff and indeed although
Raphael Warnock got more votes than
Herschel Walker neither can that it got
to 50 because of a third party candidate
and so there is going to be a runoff on
December 6th Herschel Walker in a
completely deranged weekend saying
things that don't make any sense about
anything here he is in one clip blaming
Rafael Warnock for A disruption to his
speech that was caused by an ambulance
driving by listen to this
I'm that Warrior for God that he sent
down here to get that man out of office
I'm that Warrior for God that he sent
down here because I don't dance and sing
for nobody I never have and never will
cause I remember when my office line
used to tell me there's a her should
follow me I'll take you to the promise
Lane so I'm gonna tell all of you vote
for me we all get to the promised land
because we're not gonna get about one I
want all of us to get together because
that's what we are we're God's people
and we got to get that together we're
going to work this thing out together
you guys following this do it because in
the Bible I read it sent a house the
body cannot stand I don't know what
Bible Senator Warner is reading but it's
not the Bible I've been reading because
he don't seem to be doing the right
thing by him that must be Senator we're
not doing this right here trying to
cancel me out but he can't cancel me out
cause I'm the man of God God loved me
and I can tell you that right now he
loves me and I'ma tell you this right
here cause it getting cold outside but
cold weather only make us better yeah uh
really just commenting on everything
from police responses to Godliness and
and weather and just everything at
another event uh the trend we saw was
that Walker's attacks on Warnock became
not only increasingly incoherent but
also sort of strange in this word salad
Walker tosses up the idea that Warnock
is not God's people but I started
watching television and I Came Upon A
Man by the name of Raphael wanna well
this was so funny and I'ma get into it
no no don't boom he's he's uh Everyone
Falls short and glory god let's just
think about it and he uh he is all
watching him and just the other day I
heard him preaching in his church about
me he said some of the things I said is
venomous and vile you know he said that
you know when you talk about him you're
talking about Jesus and you're talking
about Dr Luther King and this was so
funny about it he is correct when you
talk about God's people you sometimes
talk about Jesus but he's not God's
people because he's not doing right by
what God is telling him to do right
crystal clear folks this is an election
that is less about any particular issue
and more about values
consistency and who do we want
representing Us in the Senate big
picture and that's what I'm going to
come back to after we we look at the uh
Raphael Warnock clips now just one more
of Herschel Walker blaming Warnock for
something related to Archie Bunker not
being on TV anymore I mean is it these
are it's almost like a random word
generator he is a man out of coughing
like has he read the Bible I read
because they talked about forgiveness
they said don't look at this spec in
your brothers I look at the point in
your own eye you got to ask for
forgiveness and he never asked for
forgiveness and moved on he's still
talking about the past we don't want to
live in the past y'all can I tell you
this here Archer Barker will need to be
on the air today would it now and and I
tell you what I used to love Archer
bunker did you not like Archer Parker
Kobe calls him Senator what not it
wouldn't be on air because he's still
living in the past you gotta I don't
know what he's talking about
it wouldn't be on Archie Bunker went off
the air in 1983 and the guy who played
Archie Bunker died more than 20 years
ago
it's just this this is not about which
candidate's tax policy do we prefer
okay this is absurd now on the other
side of this we have a very good
candidate an uncontroversially good
candidate here is a viral ad that
Raphael Warnock put out in an extremely
sophisticated way equating Herschel
Walker's policies to dog poop is it
trust me or does it feel like we've been
here before the whole country's finished
voting and only us left you think
Herschel Walker would want to explain
what he'd do in the Senate if he
actually wants to represent Georgia
instead he repeats the same lies trying
to distract from what we all know is
true about him but I think Georges will
see his ass for what they are
don't you
I'm Rafael Warnock yeah so anyway he
dumps dog poop into a trash can when he
says I think people will see his lies
for what they are and then here is
Raphael Warnock making sure people
understand this from just a few days ago
there is going to be a runoff there is
another election coming well Georgia
here's the deal it's now clear our race
is going to a runoff on November 8th the
people of Georgia showed up you showed
out while we received more votes than my
opponent because we came up just shy of
50 of the vote we're going to a runoff
so I'm going to need all of you every
single one of you to go and vote one
more time on or before
December 6th this runoff is about who is
ready to represent you who will actually
work for Georgia it's about who will
stand up and fight for a better tomorrow
for all of our children early voting
runs November 28th through December 2nd
and runoff election day is December 6th
now nobody believes a preacher when he
says in closing but I'll close with this
go vote your vote is your voice your
voice is your human dignity and Georgia
I need you to raise your voices again
louder than ever are you ready because
I'm ready to keep working for Georgia
it's the honor of my life let's do this
thing
one more time all right so there are no
shortage there is no shortage of
opportunities to get involved you can of
course donate and many of you wrote to
me and said you have donated you can
phone bank I believe that a Cuban
American streamer Stephen Kenneth
Destiny Bonnell the second is going to
be leading a coalition of uh canvassing
down in Georgia I don't have the details
in front of me but I believe it will be
the weekend of uh you know I don't I
think it's the first couple days of
December but we can get that information
we have to get involved with this one if
Warnock wins
you knock out the power of mansion slash
Cinema like yes there's still two of
them you need one of them but you can
lose one of them and still have 50. and
that is of critical importance and we
are going to follow this one this is the
race at this point in time there is a
fight literally a verbal fight happening
right now
to be Donald Trump's vice presidential
running mate in 2024. on the one hand
you have radical and repugnant
Republican congresswoman Marjorie Taylor
green she's desperate to be Trump's VP I
told you about that last week on the
other hand you have loser Carrie Lake
who simply cannot accept more people
voted for your opponent and you lost and
it's over
they are now engaged in a battle to be
Donald Trump's vice presidential running
mate let's start with Carrie Lake who at
the very same event over the weekend
during which we already played One Clip
she said the fight is not over over the
Arizona gubernatorial race here's a
secret it's over it's over you've lost
she spent two minutes just sucking up to
Trump at that very same event making it
abundantly clear she is campaigning to
be Trump's VP listen to this groveling
my second favorite guy stood up on the
stage right up there in beautiful
Mar-A-Lago and said he's going to run
for office again and I am so excited
about that who's excited about that
there he is
and I will tell you this right now I
don't know what my future holds other
than I'm going to continue to fight for
this country but I will do everything in
my power to make sure this man gets back
in the white house we need him now more
than ever there's no other option
there's nobody better for the job
there's nobody who can get us out of
this nightmare that we're in then
somebody who introduced America First
policies can you believe so I ask you in
the coming days and months and weeks as
we're here in you know the fake news
media talk that we stand up and protect
and push and and do everything we can to
help president Trump in his move toward
the White House I will do anything in my
power to make sure this man gets in the
white house for our children's sake and
for our country's sake are you guys with
us on that
foreign a lot of campaigning for the guy
who claims he doesn't need anybody's
help really with us
[Applause]
the most beautiful place I've ever been
Mar-A-Lago
with people who are fighting for America
more like the gaudiest place she's ever
been her first policy is the only way we
get out of this mess is the is the
America First policies that President
Trump introduced and we need strong
States and strong Governors and strong
leaders from the President right on down
to the school board member let me
rephrase that we need strong leaders
from the school board right on up to the
president most importantly the school
board so thank you so much for being
here tonight thank you president Trump
for inspiring all of us and Mr President
and we are with you we've got your back
and we will be with you right until we
get you back in the White House thank
you so much all right so that is a
please pick me to be your VP sort of
speech and then as a reminder here's
Marjorie Taylor green she's desperate to
be Trump's pick for 2024 and she's
concerned that DeSantis and this was
before Carrie Lake Lost Lake really
serve a long time as Governors and not
abandon anybody because if they did it
might mean Marjory doesn't get to be
Trump's VP listen to this chlorine and
tries to challenge president Trump as
far as being the Republican nominee for
2024 we feel like it's political suicide
this is his
party this is his race to run do you
want to share your thoughts on that
absolutely I I think that it's clear and
obvious president Trump is the People's
Choice he's the one that we elected in
2016. we re-elected him in 2020 and we
will elect him in 2024. what we need in
this country Brian is we need strong
Republican Governors like Ron DeSantis
we need strong Republican Governors we
need Kerry Lake to win in Arizona we
need strong Republican Governors to
fight stay in for eight years and save
their states eight years just long
enough that they wouldn't be able to
either run for president if you're
talking about DeSantis or be Trump's VP
if you're talking about Kerry Lake not
to abandon their states and try to run
for president or any other big position
could she be any more obvious in what
she's trying to do the last thing we
need I mean for the party right for the
movement but for the movement the best
thing would be DeSantis should be
Governor multiple more times Kerry Lake
should be governor for close to a decade
they should not try to run for president
she's campaigning for herself as VP only
a trump supporter would see primary
Trump as an act of betrayal and this is
going to be extraordinary once it gets
going let me know what you think make
sure you're subscribed on YouTube at
youtube.com slash the David Pacman show
much more coming up today
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
there is an argument being made by
opinion writer Keith Naughton in the
hill that Donald Trump may not make it
to the primaries forget about Trump
might not win the Republican primary
Naughton is arguing that Trump may not
even make it to the primaries let's
explore whether this might be possible
one of the things that Naughton asks is
whether Trump could quote flame out and
not even make it to the Iowa caucuses
and not in his article and I will link
to it I encourage you to read it lists a
number of sort of strategic and polling
and legal issues that could affect
Donald Trump to start with Naughton
argues you know Trump's polling is kind
of soft when you think about the fact
that he's a former president
and that he's declared and no one else
has and that that polling support for
Trump is already getting worse since
November 8th Trump isn't even scoring 50
percent against people that aren't
running so the first question is check
the facts is that true and the answer is
it is absolutely true if you look at
recent polling
um in Trump versus DeSantis there's a
newish Harris poll which does have Trump
well ahead of DeSantis but remember that
DeSantis hasn't even announced that he's
running and Trump still can't get to 50
percent in a Republican primary this is
not a national poll here this is the
Republican primary poll former president
only guy who's announced not polling 50
that is a concern there is a yougov poll
from a few days prior this is from last
week
that one straight up has Trump losing
Trump is losing to DeSantis who is not
even running at this point in time so in
thinking through Keith Naughton's
argument
so far he's correct Donald Trump is
losing a bunch of polls and even in the
polls that he's winning he's failing to
get 50 percent
in a primary
against people who aren't even running
that is not good for a former president
now the counter to the poll story you
all know the counter to the poll story
which was in 2015 into 2016 during the
last contested Republican primary
people were saying the same thing this
guy can't win he's doesn't have the
polling support it's going to be Jeb or
it's going to be Ted Cruz or it's going
to be somebody else you know Marco Rubio
I don't know whoever Ron Rand Paul
um and everybody who said that was wrong
the difference is now
it's a little bit weirder that Trump has
such soft polling even after announcing
despite the fact that he's all polling
against people who aren't even running
because he spent four years as president
and he is in a sense the leader of the
Republican party or at least has been
for a period of time so I think that is
a concern the next problem that Keith
Naughton points out in his article is
that Trump has nothing new to offer
now the question is whether that's a
problem it's absolutely true
if you listen to Trump's announcement
speech it was verbatim the same speech
he's been giving for a year or even
longer
whether it's a problem that Trump has
nothing new to say remains to be seen do
people want something new and I believe
the answer there is it depends who
you're talking about
Trump's hard and fast followers who buy
the gear
go to the rallies repost the memes those
types of people I don't think they want
anything new they want the exact same
speech about you know teaching
transgender and we're going to ban men
and all this different stuff but there
is a growing faction of the Republican
party some of them have been interviewed
on Fox News recently who want something
new and different the difficulty for
Trump is he can't win just with his base
That Base lost him 2020. and some of
them are becoming demoralized so you've
got to find some new people and the same
messaging is unlikely to capture it I
think he's absolutely correct there
Naughton also talks about the
unpredictable nature of Trump's legal
troubles and how those may impact what
happens in this campaign I think that
that is true it's a real consideration
we just don't know the full scope of
what will happen which makes it
difficult to say here's how it will
affect Trump's race lastly
how does Naughton get to Trump May quit
before the primaries Naughton's argument
is that for Trump quitting and saying I
don't need this crap it's my choice I'm
going back to be a rich guy or whatever
it's better than Trump losing a primary
and that's why Keith Naughton in his
piece for the hill argues this is not
going to go well for Trump the polling
will be so bad that even Trump will be
worried because remember if the
polling's a little bad Trump will come
up with oh that's push-pulling and
they're trying to get people to stay
home I don't believe the polling the
polling may be so bad that Trump will
believe I've got to get out rather than
be humiliated by not even as the former
president losing a primary is very
embarrassing there is one more
interesting point here
can we imagine Trump winning a New
Hampshire primary right now a republican
New Hampshire primary the last poll from
which is one of the early primaries the
last poll from New Hampshire was from
UNH in June June and it had DeSantis up
by two in New Hampshire Trump hadn't
announced and DeSantis hadn't announced
Trump's problems have grown since June
and DeSantis favor has increased among
Republicans since June
if it's so difficult to imagine Trump
winning a New Hampshire Republican
primary
Keith Naughton's argument starts to make
a lot more sense what do you think let
me know in the comments on YouTube and
make sure that you're subscribed we
wondered whether it was coming and it
has Donald Trump has been unbanned from
Twitter but as of this moment he hasn't
posted a damn thing and recently said
that he did not plan to return to
Twitter even if he was unbanned NPR
reporting on this Elon Musk allows
Donald Trump back on Twitter now what
Elon Musk did was he put out a tweet and
he said should I reinstate Trump to
Twitter
and despite all the claims about how
much of a left-wing Echo chamber Twitter
is and how it's all radical left Bots uh
the yes reinstate votes won on Twitter
claiming that he was representing the
will of the people Elon Musk then went
and had Donald Trump unbanned a quick
look at Donald Trump's Twitter account
shows that his most recent tweet
was uh almost two years old January 8
2021 where he said to all of those who
have asked I will not be going to the
inauguration
on January 20th
and of course he did not go to the
inauguration of Joe Biden he left
Washington DC before that the one listen
I don't know whether Trump's going to
come back to Twitter quite frankly I
don't care there's a couple interesting
things here number one
this decision by Elon Musk could torpedo
truth social
essential and the reason why is as
follows
Trump has said I'm not going back on
Twitter truth social is the place where
everything is happening and Trump is in
the middle of trying to uh sell or raise
money for truth social to the tune of
hundreds of millions because truth
social is going down in flames
even if Trump doesn't go back on Twitter
it's harder to imagine that investors
would be as interested in truth social
given that one of the main reasons for
its existence and creation was that
Trump was banned from Twitter so we'll
see how that shakes out and it would be
interesting if this decision by musk
ends up torpedoing torpedoing truth
social the other thing is that Elon Musk
is of course seemingly gone back on his
own word Elon Musk at the end of October
said he is not going to be unbanning any
accounts until a new content moderation
Council forms
we are not aware of such a council
forming and so big shocker Elon Musk
seems to have gone back on his own word
unbanning Donald Trump on the say-so of
his own followers rather than because of
this content moderation Council Will
trump ultimately be able to resist going
back on Twitter I have no idea let me
know what you think I think it's totally
plausible Trump stays off of it I think
it's also totally plausible that if
indeed his campaign continues to not get
the attention that Trump wanted to get
he will get desperate and try to find a
way to get more attention and maybe
going on Twitter would be exactly that
let me know what you think we have a
voicemail number that number is
2192 David P
today's caller
asks a very personal question
about parenting
listen to this
hi David are you the kind of father that
would spank your children and wife
no
no I I don't even do do I really need to
say more I mean do
the answer is is no
uh let's just leave it there we have a
fantastic bonus show for you today
the World Cup has started in Qatar
I am genuinely
split 50 50. on the one hand I could not
be more disgusted at the lead up so let
me listen
corruption in the selection of Qatar to
even host a World Cup
use of what is essentially slave labor
indentured servitude to build the
stadiums in Qatar most recently Qatar
won't allow any kosher food or public
Jewish prayer
in and around the World Cup this is a
horrible
extremist authoritarian regime
on the other hand as an Argentinian
I love the world cup and I love watching
the Argentinian Men's National Team I'm
thinking about getting up at 5am
tomorrow to watch the first game
and this is
um we're going to talk about World Cup
and what's going on in Qatar on the
bonus show that's number one secondly
CBS News went on Hiatus from Twitter
after
uh supposedly over security concerns
and then is now back to posting on
Twitter what happened is it weird is it
a call for attention what's going on we
will discuss it and thirdly NASA is now
saying that by the year 2030 this is
only you know eight years away at this
point by the year 2030
astronauts will be living and working on
the moon you know we heard all these
predictions about we would be on Mars by
2024 we're not going to be
um
etc etc that don't seem plausible they
never seemed plausible Mars 2028 it's
seeming a little difficult but maybe
working and living on the Moon by 2030
seems much more plausible but will it
happen and what would be the point we're
going to talk about those stories and
more on today's bonus show this is a
shortened week just so everybody knows
we are here Monday Tuesday Wednesday we
will then be off the rest of the week
for the Thanksgiving federal holiday in
the United States Monday Tuesday
Wednesday will sort of be like a Friday
show and we will have new content on the
Pacman Finance Channel we will have new
content on Pacman live everything else
will sort of be normal but it'll just be
a shortened week for the holiday and
then we will be indeed uh back next week
we're gonna speak to you on the bonus
show you can sign up at
joinpakman.com oh the bonus show where
you want to make money yeah everybody
else that makes money to fund themselves
is bad yeah Alex Jones is the last
person at this point to be commenting on
business advice given what's going on
with his hemorrhaging of money uh but
yes you sign up at joinpakman.com you
can use the coupon code 24 starts now
and very soon May maybe tomorrow
maybe Wednesday
I will be able to announce the release
of our first white paper I think you're
gonna like this talk to you on the bonus
show or otherwise tomorrow